Now in the previous lecture, I talked about how we can actually mathematically
represent the whole concept of smoothing applied to images.
We looked at a specific instance of being able to smooth an image with a kernel.
You may recall that in that lecture, we looked at how we
can actually mathematically represent this process of taking a kernel and
applying it to a small region, a three by three one, in this sample image.
While this was for just doing the averaging,
we can also do this in general terms for any kind of an image.
And we came up with a term, or a mathematical formulation,
which basically now let's you loop over the whole image, but
also provide non-uniform weights to each and every one of them to be
able to create a general equation of how we can do any kind of filtering.
In the last lecture, I referred to this term, or this process,
as cross-correlation, which was an attempt to basically loop over an image, or
as part of an image in this instance, and expand this over
the whole image with a kernel, which basically was not trying to change, and
put non-uniform weights to be able to impact the output image.
And again, we would loop over the entire image this way.
Now we want to actually start looking at this whole concept of
cross-correlation in a little bit more in detail